so she came seven on ESPN do like when
does that start I don't know
so UFC is gonna be on ESPN now yeah no
more Fox this year Fox an ESPN we're
gonna split it right yeah and then Fox
didn't want to pay like the premium but
I think it's better I think I think it
was a homerun for the UFC man to land at
ESPN it's you know it's as serious as it
gets as far as major sports it's on one
network when it and also with ESPN XI of
ESPN Plus which we get some fight nights
and you have regular ESPN espn2 with Fox
not that they do a great job but it was
FXX fs2 it's like you know we're is
there is it and announced on UFC fight
pass and out tear and she's just going I
think yes PN can learn from mistakes
from Fox and just make it that much
better
I think you're right about that because
there's been some times that I thought I
had my DVR set but then I get home and
it was on fs1 I'm like mother [ __ ] or
sometimes like my batter it's like my
bat NASCAR's playing so go to FXX time
[ __ ] man
we're a baseball game goes long and you
got to go FS - yes I'm gonna find it
that's 672 my only concern on ESPN is
because ESPN FC has NFL his MBA how much
how much focus are you then put on the
UFC you know like we don't be the side
chick right because they're made to the
NBA NFL that's that that's their baby
are we that is the UFC give me the side
chick you know right good but we don't
want but they've been putting on some
good boxing matches
they're the lomachenko contracted loan
Jenkins yeah they had they had another
really good fight on recently yeah Jake
on my podcast coming up ooh yeah yeah
aside for that I'm gonna sing glitches
but we'll figure it out
yeah I'm they contacted me too yeah I
think I'm gonna have them on as well
might as well might as well I got
questions I got a lot of watch yours
first learn from my mistakes